RACHEL: So without further
ado, please welcome Dr. Judith
Wright.
[APPLAUSE]
JUDITH WRIGHT: All of you,
I'm so glad to see all of you.
Let me assume, given the
topic, how many of you
want a great relationship?
Can I see that?
Yeah.
How many of you want
one that's horrible?
I don't think many.
I think we all want that.
But let me ask you this.
Who is committed to having
great relationships?
And if you are, stand up,
because that puts more
of the commitment out there.
Let's just see.
If you're committed
to having a--
Now we're going to do
a little mini relating.
Really quickly, say hello
to at least another person
so that we're really starting
the whole thing with relating.
Hi, hi, hi to you
in the live stream.
That's great.
Good.
Thank you.
You can come back
and take you seats.
That's great.
Because if we're not willing to
relate, and risk, and get out
of our comfort zone,
then it's really hard
to have satisfying
relationships at work
or in our personal lives.
So I really want to thank
you, Rachel, for having me.
It's great to be back.
Thank you so much.
And to Google for hosting
these wonderful opportunities
to be able to share
ideas with one another.
I also want to acknowledge
the transformers.
We've had this blessing to coach
couples for over 30-some years,
actually from pre-marital
work all the way through
from empty nesting.
We know what the whole arc
is now over all this time.
And we work with not
just couples in trouble,
but couples who really want
to just play this game of what
is possible in intimacy.
How can we take
relationships farther
than people have taken them?
How do we go beyond our
parents and grandparents?
What's possible in
intimate relationships?
So there's been this
grand experiment
for over 30-some
years which we've
done as part of the
Wright Foundation
for the Realization of
Human Potential, where
we do everything we can to
bring out the best in people,
to energize their lives, and
to also ignite their world.
So becoming the very best
person you can become obviously
changes the people
around you, which
is our mission, so that we
can have a planet that's
conscious and sustainable.
And we try to work on
it one person at a time
is how our mission works.
So we've also been
studying these people who
have dedicated themselves
to, really, what's possible,
who can I become?
And also dedicating to
intimacy and relationships.
So these transformers,
I call them,
who've been working this couples
work for all these years-- not
all of them have been
in 30 years, obviously.
The program's been
going in that way.
But our divorce rate
is 4% to 9% as opposed
to the divorce rate in our
country, which is over 50%.
And that's actually not
the most important thing.
The most important
thing is they're really
thriving, satisfying, juicy,
intimate, growing, evolving
relationships.
And that's what I
am interested in.
And I also want to thank all the
researchers and all the people
we pulled together.
And we've been
studying everything
we can about relationships at
the Wright Graduate University.
And we teach this.
And we pull together
the most relevant,
emerging technologies
and research
to these kind of topics.
And all the thinkers
and researchers
whose work we pulled together.
And I want to also thank
my husband and my partner.
Because part of my research is
my own relationship with my guy
over-- it'll be 35
years in a month.
So I know of what I speak.
I know what works well.
And I know what doesn't.
And I'm going to share a
lot of that with you today.
Let me find out a little
bit more about you.
How many of you are
in a relationship,
a committed
relationship, right now?
OK.
How many of you are
or have been divorced
at some point in your life?
Who's dating or should be?
I guess you're
single [INAUDIBLE].
How many of you have ever
had a tough break up?
How many of you wish
you'd broken up sooner?
Yeah, I know.
I know that one too.
I'm sure there's a lot of
stories that we all have.
And I'm going to be focusing a
lot on intimate relationships,
but everything I'm
talking about relates
to all kinds of relationships--
with work relationships,
family relationships,
friend relationships.
Let me find out.
How many of you want better
relationships with friends?
Let me look at that.
OK, great.
Me too.
Coworkers?
Teams at work?
Bosses?
How about bosses?
Yeah, that's OK.
Then your family?
Let me see that.
How many would like
better dating experiences,
whatever that might be?
OK.
Who would just
like more intimacy
in the relationships you have?
How about just more
love, in any way
you define that for yourself?
How about more phenomenal sex?
I'm not going to
talk about that,
but I thought that would
get you interested.
Although the things
we're talking about
do contribute because
the ways that we relate
that get ourselves
more available,
get us closer and
closer to one another.
So again, what I'm
going to talk about
is going to affect everything.
And I'm really
excited to be with you
and appreciate this opportunity.
And if you are
interested and there's
something you
would like more of,
I have a special gift for
you toward the end that I'm
excited to share with you.
So let's look at this.
We all want great relationships.
They're one of the most
important things to all of us.
It's the thing that means the
most to me in my own life.
Yet, they don't always work
out, or we don't always
have the skills to do what it
is that we need to be doing.
So I want to look
together with you.
I'm going to ask you to
work with me a little bit.
I'm going to divide the
room up a little bit,
maybe about right here.
So this side of the room,
I'll give you one assignment.
And this side of the
room-- actually, there's
more of you on this side.
Oops.
So we're going to
cut it right here.
I'm going to cut
you right in half.
So this way, you'll be
one, and then the rest.
What I'd like for you to
do is just get together
with two or three people.
Turn around so you've got a
group of two or three people.
And I want you to brainstorm
for a minute on this side what
makes a great relationship.
And on this side, if you gather
together just for one minute,
what makes a bad relationship?
With are terrible relationships?
What are the elements of
just bad relationships,
whether they're love
relationships, work
relationships, family,
whatever it is.
Bad relationships,
good relationships.
If you just grab a
couple people and just
brainstorm for a minute.
And I'll call you
back in a moment.
I'll raise my hand when it's
time for us to come back.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
Just about another 10 seconds.
OK, if you'd finish that
thought and come on back.
We'll brainstorm together.
Come on back.
And if we do some
discussions throughout this,
I'll raise my hand,
and if you see my hand,
that's our signal to come back.
If you didn't raise your
hand, then be quiet.
That would help bring
the energy back.
But you're pretty good.
You're well-trained.
So let me find out.
Let's start with what's bad.
What are the elements
of a bad relationship?
Can you shout some
things out to me.
What did you come up with?
AUDIENCE: A lack
of communication.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Lack
What else?
AUDIENCE: Self-centered.
JUDITH WRIGHT:
Self centeredness.
Yeah, good.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Disrespect.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Disrespect.
AUDIENCE: Blaming.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Blaming.
Oh, yeah.
That's a biggy.
Yeah.
Good.
Not that any of us ever do that.
But you know, others we've
known, they've had that happen.
Well, let's find
out what they say,
and then probably
whatever the opposite is
of that is probably what
we would have on this side.
So what are the elements
of a good relationship,
a great relationship?
Oops.
Like that.
Sorry.
What was that?
AUDIENCE: More positives
than negatives.
JUDITH WRIGHT: More
positive than negatives.
Great.
Perfect.
Thank you.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Communication.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Communication.
AUDIENCE: Respect.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Respect,
which you had disrespect.
Thank you.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Chemistry.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Chemistry.
Good.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Honesty.
JUDITH WRIGHT:
What was that one?
AUDIENCE: Honesty.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Honesty.
Good.
Well, all right,
this is interesting.
And it's common knowledge
of the kind of things
that we're looking at.
But I really want us
to be aware of what
you think are great
relationships, what makes them,
and what makes bad ones.
Because then we're going to
compare it to the research,
and see what we found and
what researchers have found.
How accurate are we?
So I wanted to get
you started with that.
So one of the things
I'd like to start with
is let's look at
that quiz you took.
And if you didn't
take it, you can maybe
come along with the rest of us.
And those of you in
the live stream, we'll
summarize some of
the concepts soon.
All right, look at the quiz.
And what I'd like you to do
is take your little quiz,
that little card, and count
all of your true responses.
Count all the true choices.
How many trues did you have.
We'll start with that.
Counting.
I think most of you got it.
All right, how many of
you had all 20 true?
How about between 15 and 20,
maybe somewhere in there?
OK.
10 to 15?
And how about 5 to 10?
OK.
Perfect.
And anybody less than 5?
OK, good.
So if you answered true to
any one of these questions,
you are under the mythology
of romance and relationships,
because none of them are true.
Absolutely none
of them are true.
None.
Did I say none?
I think I said none.
So none of them are true.
Because this is what's
really interesting-- those
of you in the webcast,
the live stream,
you can see a little bit
of what we're looking at.
Because we think these are--
they're all relationship
myths that limit intimacy
and really keep us
from having the kind of
contact and connection
we can have with others.
And in fact, the higher your
ratio of true to false, then
the more you're under the
influence of this relationship
mythology.
And these are just a sample.
This isn't all of them.
Alfred Adler says
that each of us
has these fictive
goals that we have.
We imagine these things
and expecting something
from relationships that
just aren't realistic
and really set us up.
So this is part of what
I wanted to look at.
They set us up for
relationship failure too,
that if you believe
them to be true,
you don't focus on
what it really takes
to have great relationships.
And that's part of
the problem with them.
They take our
attention from what we
need to be paying attention to.
And even if we know they're not
true-- I know they're not true,
and I'm still
under the influence
of these, which is really
interesting to see of this.
If we just look at this in the
bigger sense, how many of you
would like more romance
in your life, however
you define that for yourself?
The women and the men are too.
I don't mean to be
sexist about that.
But I think it's
something important.
But let's look at that.
Let's look at
romance for a moment.
And, Katie, if you could do
that one, that would be great.
I want to show you
a little video clip.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-It's a silly rose.
-It's beautiful.
-Vivian!
Vivian!
[BELLS]
-No matter how your
heart is grieving,
if you keep on believing,
the dream that you wish
will come true.
[END PLAYBACK]
[LAUGHTER]
JUDITH WRIGHT: Yeah, I know.
I know that this is a myth of
romance, and I cannot tell you,
I get totally turned on by this.
I have chills, and my
heart's going pitter patter.
And I know better.
So I am not alone with this.
So that is part of it.
But let's look at this.
What did you notice
in these clips?
What's the quality
of what's going on?
AUDIENCE: Lots of Richard Gere.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Lots
of Richard Gere.
I know.
Richard Gere.
Like, what?
Isn't that amazing?
I know.
It's hilarious.
What else did you notice?
AUDIENCE: Grand gestures.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Grand gestures,
totally grand gestures.
Yeah.
And how about the conversations?
[LAUGHTER]
There's like none.
There's a soundtrack,
and nobody's talking.
You don't know anybody.
It's just this thing.
You get whisked away.
This is what's implanted
in our minds in that way.
And that's why we are forever
fighting these illusions
in our work.
And even when we know
better intellectually,
they still are part
of our culture.
In fact, studies show
that 78% of people
have Cinderella type elements in
their notions of romantic love
and how we think--
not just romantic.
In this way, it's romantic.
But what relationships
are supposed to be like.
And when you have that, and
most people do to some degree,
you experience a lot
of disillusionment,
and angst, and disappointment
in relationships.
And the research
shows that as well.
So here's the issue.
Most everything we are
taught about relationships
doesn't work.
It is wrong, the things
that are in our culture.
There are certainly some
good things out there,
but the bulk of it is not.
Often, they don't lead
to great relationships.
Oftentimes, advice we
get is actually harmful,
actually creates a
lack of connection.
And they're found in
these relationship myths
and misconceptions, starting
with this myth of romance.
And I want to go into
that a little bit more
just so we can use that as
an overall context for some
of the things we're
going to talk about.
This is what the dictionary,
how it defines romance.
It's really interesting.
First one is "a love affair,
especially a brief and intense
one."
And the second one is
"sexual love, especially when
the other person
or the relationship
is idealized and not real."
Great.
Romance means you have a
brief, fake love affair.
Awesome.
And this is what
we want more of.
That's kind of wild
when you look at that.
So wouldn't we
rather have a love
affair that isn't just brief?
Or a sexual love that's
actually with a real person?
Where we're real and
connected with one another?
Like, hello?
The third definition though
is really interesting.
And I want to use it to
frame what we're going
to be talking about today.
It's romance defined
a little differently.
Romance is an exciting
adventure with "the potential
for heroic achievement."
Now this is more interesting.
This is what we're
looking at here.
Now this means that
you have to have,
really, the courage that it
takes to be real, and present,
and authentic.
Where you're sharing
your fears and your joys,
your tears and your happiness,
your gifts and your weaknesses.
You're telling the truth.
Because it's really easy to
woo someone with chocolates,
and flowers, or whatever.
It's easy to make
reservations for dinner.
It's really difficult to
share your reservations
about yourself, or
about your partner,
or about the people around
you, or your friends,
or about the
relationship itself.
And this is the crux
of what this is really
about to have intimate,
thriving relationships.
It's easy to ask somebody
out to see a movie.
Well, actually, it's not
all that easy sometimes.
Sometimes, that's kind of hard.
But it's harder to ask someone
to really see you fully
for who you are and to really
ask them to reveal themselves
that deeply so you
really can see them.
So what you want to look at
is, what is the real truth?
If it's not the myth of
romance, then what is it?
What is it that really creates
thriving relationships?
Those of you that are interested
in business relationships,
I am focusing this more
on couples for today,
but everything
we're talking about
is applicable to
business situations,
and to work, and to teams.
We use this in our
consulting, and our teaching,
and our training in businesses
and companies every day.
So you'll have to do
a little translating.
I'll do some of it for you.
But I want to make this point
about it because the concepts
are the same.
The way we need to engage in
our romantic relationships
is the same we need to engage
at work, and with our families,
and everyone.
It's being ourselves fully, and
we're going to look at that.
But let's look at this.
I want to show us "The Heart
of the Fight" [? truth. ?]
It's this heroic adventure,
not quite the movie type.
But what is the truth?
What is really the opposite of
this, and what do we go for?
I'm going to show
you another clip that
shows the beginning of a
beautiful relationship.
And I want you just to sense
what you feel with this one
and see how that relates
to what we just looked at.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You're bored.
You're bored and you know it.
You wouldn't be here if there
wasn't something missing.
-Arrogant son of a bitch.
-Would you just stay with me?
-Stay with you?
What for?
Look at us.
We're already fighting.
-Well, that's what we do.
We fight.
You tell me when I'm being
an arrogant son of a bitch,
and I tell you when you're
being a pain in the ass.
Which you are 99% of the time.
I'm not afraid to
hurt your feelings.
They have like a two
second rebound rate,
and you're back doing the
next pain in the ass thing.
-So what?
-So it's not going to be easy.
It's going to be really hard.
And we're going to have
to work at this every day,
but I want to do that,
because I want you.
I want all of you.
Forever.
You and me.
Every day.
Will you do something for me?
Please?
Will you just picture
your life for me?
30 years from now, 40 years
from now, what's it look like?
If it's with that guy, go.
Go.
I lost you once, I think
I could do it again,
if I thought that's
what you really wanted.
But don't you take
the easy way out.
-What easy way?
There is no easy way.
No matter what I do,
somebody gets hurt.
-Would you stop thinking
about what everyone wants?
Stop thinking about what
I want, what he wants,
what your parents want.
What do you want?
-It's not that simple.
-What do you want?
Damn it, what do you want?
[END PLAYBACK]
JUDITH WRIGHT: Wow.
I know.
So what's the movie?
AUDIENCE: "The Notebook."
JUDITH WRIGHT: "The
Notebook," "The Notebook."
All right.
Let's just look
at this a minute.
So what's the difference in
this clip than what we just
watched before?
So what do you know?
What's the quality
of this relationship?
AUDIENCE: They're talking.
JUDITH WRIGHT: They're
talking, for one.
But then they're
talking genuinely,
and they're in
each other's faces.
They're fighting.
They're fully there.
They're going for what
they really need and want.
And he's asking her,
don't try to please me.
Do what it is that
you need to be doing.
That's a whole different
kind of love going on here.
There's something
much more real.
So if you compare
this to fairy tales,
fairy tales don't have
room for the tough times.
They don't have
room for fighting.
They don't have room for
the truth in that way.
They're nice.
They're not real.
They're not fighting.
Great relationships
have great fights,
and I think this is an
example of one of those.
And being real instead of nice.
And instead living
happily ever after,
I'm proposing we live
deeply ever after.
Because that's
where the juice is.
That's where the growth
is and the intimacy is.
So if I look at
these myths, I've
started out with
the myth of romance
because I want to set
this context of how
that gets in our way.
But there's several other myths.
Let me show you the ones
that we want to look at.
There's a myth of romance.
There's a myth of relationships
are supposed to make you happy.
There's a myth of love means
you accept me for who I am.
There's a myth of the
one or a soul mate.
There's a myth of compatibility.
And one of you said chemistry.
Chemistry is a myth also.
The other is a myth of
attraction, somewhat related.
Or if it's love, it should be
easy, or all you need is love.
So I can go through all
of these or any of these.
Which ones do you
want to fight me on?
Which ones-- no, this
one has to be true.
Are there any that bug you more?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The one
about acceptance.
JUDITH WRIGHT: About
acceptance, all right.
Anybody else?
What else?
AUDIENCE: Chemistry.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Chemistry.
AUDIENCE: Attraction.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Attraction.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Soul mate.
JUDITH WRIGHT:
What was that one?
Soul mate.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Compatibility.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Compatibility.
All right, you're
picking most of them.
So maybe we'll just go
at it, because these
are the things I think
most of us are looking for.
So I'll try to run through as
many as I can, and we'll see.
So the first one's-- actually,
I don't think any of you said
this one, but I'm
going to do this.
If I had a relationship,
then I'd be happy.
Let me just set that.
This is the happily
ever after thing.
So she's, wow, if I just
had that, then I'd be happy.
Turns out the research
is that no, it
may boost your happiness for a
little bit, up to maybe a year
and a half or two,
but after that, we
go right back to the
level of happiness
we had before we got
in a relationship.
It appears we have a
happiness set point.
And nobody's going to
change that for us.
The only person that can
make us happy is ourselves.
Nobody else can do that, as
much as we want them to do.
So what the issue with
this is that what happens
if we expect a relationship
to make us happy,
and when the inevitable
problems come up,
then we think there's something
wrong with the relationship
rather than what
could be happening.
So each of us is
100% responsible
for our own satisfaction
and happiness.
That's one of our
rules of engagement
that I think I'll talk
about a little bit later.
And the purpose
of a relationship
is not to make you happy.
It's for you to learn,
and to grow, and to become
the best person you can become.
And that's a very different
premise in that way.
So who wanted the
accept me for who I am?
Somebody over-- yeah, OK.
Great.
Let's look at that one.
Love means you accept
me for who I am.
I mean, we're all
hungry for that.
We want somebody to
love us for who we are.
Some acceptance, of
course, is helpful.
But it also can be an
excuse for poor behavior.
Hey, just love me the way I am.
So you don't work that way.
And a lot--
[LAUGHTER]
And a lot of women
sometimes think
they're being-- and
others, and men as well--
think they're being accepted,
but actually, they're
really not being seen
or even dealt with.
They're not known.
And that's not really accepting.
So the real truth of
this one is that what's
really important that we
found in our own research
and other researchers
have found is
it's more important to love who
you are becoming, who you could
be, not just who you
are, which is really
an important
difference in that way.
Because what makes great
relationships is supporting
your partner to become the very
best person they can become.
Supporting the people that you
work with to become their best.
Supporting your friends
to become their best.
That's where relationships
start taking off.
And it's not supporting them
to be who you want them to be.
It's supporting them to become
who they want to become.
Who is their ideal self?
What is their
vision for themself?
And how can you empower that?
That's what creates
intimacy in relationships.
And in fact, the more
your relationship
results in you
learning, and growing,
and new things that make you a
better person, the better, much
more satisfying relationships.
Whether this is at home or at
work, it's very much the same.
And the more self-expansion,
they call it,
that you experience through
being with this person,
through new ideas, novel
ways of looking at things,
new perspectives,
the more satisfied
you are and the more committed
you are in the relationship.
There's another thing called
the Michelangelo effect,
Michelangelo phenomenon.
Where, if you're conscious, and
this is really conscious living
in relationship, if
you're conscious,
every interaction
can help sculpt you
and the person that you're with
into becoming their next-- we
call it your next most
radiant self, that you you
haven't become yet.
That if you look at your
relationship that way,
that that's its purpose, to
really dive in in that way,
to sculpt our best self.
The purpose of a relationship
is not to accept who you are,
it's to become who
you could become.
And that's a different
focus for what relationships
are really about, and the
one that really works.
Who wanted soul mate?
Yeah, all right, good.
This one's a popular one.
73% of Americans
believe that they
are destined to find
their one, true soul mate.
But what happens, if
you believe in that,
it makes it actually
much more difficult
to have intimacy
because you romanticize.
It doesn't last.
It doesn't lead to
real relationships.
It's passionate at first.
But when problems
arise, you figure
you just have the wrong one.
This must not be my
soul mate, so you don't
tend to invest in the same way.
You think you're not
meant for one another.
So you leave.
You give up on it pretty early.
What they're finding is you
tend to be more anxious and less
likely to forgive if you
have that kind of framework
in your mind.
You start looking
for the right person.
This one's not it.
I'm going to get back on
the market or whatever.
And you know what it leads to?
Really great one night stands.
Passionate, short,
brief, flaming, wow.
It's great for that.
But long-term intimacy, no.
Short-term fiery ones, yeah.
But not long-term.
Because what we're
finding is that believing
in cultivating
relationships, you're
less likely to reject your
partner over dissatisfaction.
You're more likely
to dive into them,
and learn, and grow,
which is really important,
and become more understanding
of yourself and the other.
So more importantly,
rather than looking
for your soul mate, look for
someone who is willing to grow,
look for someone who's
willing to become,
willing to grow with
you in that way,
and who's willing to work on
themselves in the relationship,
do the hard work in becoming
who they can become.
The more you believe that
relationships evolve, and grow,
and deepen with hard
work, the better.
So it's not finding
the right person,
it's being the right person.
If some of you are
single, be the person
that you would like to marry.
Whatever those elements are, you
be that, and then attract that
to you.
That's what's important.
Not looking to get completed.
I mean, you complete me.
Ugh.
No, complete yourself.
And then let somebody
add to that for you,
but not about being
completed in that way.
Let's look at compatibility
because one of you
said that too.
All right.
So many of us believe that
having a lot in common
means that we're
meant to be together.
We both have the same tattoos.
If you look at
dating sites, yeah.
Dating sites are
like, I'm looking
for someone who likes
the same stuff I
like, and lets go do stuff.
Think of, oh, romantic
walks on the beach,
or certain philosophies, or
literature, or Mexican food,
whatever it is, as if that's
going to be the thing that's
going to make us connect.
It's not.
Because compatibility
is totally overrated.
Really compatible
couples, people,
are not more
happier than others.
When people say
we're not compatible,
what they usually mean is
we're not getting along.
It's really not about
what this is about.
Great relationships
change over time.
We use what we call the law
of complementarity, where
you can look for
people who are actually
even different than you
that you can learn from,
that can rub your edges in
a way, that are sometimes
even irritating, but
it's helping you.
You don't feel so comfortable.
You're more learning
from one another.
And in that way, like
in my relationship,
I was the quieter one,
believe it or not.
I was the quieter one
in the relationship.
I was a little more introverted.
My husband's opinionated, and
straight-talking, and truthful,
and straight out, and assertive.
I really had to learn from him.
I've been going to
school on him how
to express myself more fully.
He's been going to school
on me on more of acceptance.
So we're learning
from one another,
but not expecting
ourselves to be the same.
Except when we do,
and then we fight,
and I'll tell you more
about when that happens.
More importantly
is common values,
common purposes, not
common interests,
which I think makes
sense when we say this.
OK, who are my chemistry ones?
We had a few people that
wanted to look at chemistry.
All right, let's
look at this one.
So here's the issue
with chemistry.
When the chemistry
is great, we don't
have meaningful
combative discussions
about what really matters.
We are relating with our bodies,
not our minds, which is great.
But let's not
pretend that that's
the only thing that helps
us have these relationships.
So what happens is that
with this chemistry,
there's this chemical rush.
It's a surge of chemicals, and
these hormones, and serotonin,
and dopamine is moving
through our bodies.
And if you do a brain
scan of someone when
we're looking and
thinking about our beloved
when we're in these
lustful parts of it,
your brain looks like you've
got an obsession compulsion
disorder or you're
really on drugs.
We are so high.
We are just high.
It's that love sick feeling,
all these chemicals racing
through our system.
But the chemicals,
we're high, we're
obsessed, in an altered state.
But the chemicals don't last.
They're not meant to.
They never last.
And then people think, oh,
when the chemistry invariably
weakens, they think
there's something
wrong with the relationship.
I'm not attracted
to them anymore.
We don't have any chemistry.
No.
It ran its course.
It's supposed to because
no chemical reaction just
keeps going.
Maybe some do, but they
complete themselves.
So what could be
happening though,
it just got you together in a
way where you're getting ready
for the next levels of
relationship, which are really
where it starts to
become interesting.
Companionate love
is the part of this.
So I want to look at
that for a second, which
is the combination of being
securely attached and connected
to another person,
having more intimacy,
having deep affection.
And you can have
this with friends,
you can have this as coworkers.
It doesn't just have
to be loved ones.
And then toward more consummate
love, which many people
consider-- let me
go back to that--
the most blissful
kind of love possible,
where you have attraction,
and passion, and commitment,
and security, and realness.
There's a depth of relationship
that you're getting ready for.
But if we think it's
just about the chemistry,
we won't allow
ourselves to do the work
to evolve to these
other parts of relating.
This is related.
Somebody said attraction,
so we're going
to go to that one for a second.
This is related to chemistry.
But what happens,
we are attracted
to people that is an
unconscious response to people
who, unknowingly to us,
represent our parents.
So what happens, they represent
aspects of our relationship
with a parent.
So for example, if you
had a distant father,
for a woman, maybe
perhaps you're
attracted to more distant men.
Or sometimes, you can go
the opposite way with that.
So you maybe had more of an
abusive father, for example,
you might try to go toward
more milquetoast men
to try to avoid that.
But it has an impact on
who we're attracted to.
So the same thing.
If you can see these
childhood kinds of things.
Maybe your father was somewhat
of a jerk in some ways.
But you will be
attracted to jerks.
I just want you to
understand that.
That that will be
what turns you on.
Because what happens, we have
this attachment relationship
schema that's formed
when we're very young.
It forms in these neural
pathways of our beliefs
and our feelings.
And whatever felt like love
to us when we were young
is what we think love is.
And if it doesn't
feel like that,
we don't get attracted to it.
So we don't know
this consciously,
but that's what's
going on inside of us.
How many of you have
gotten attracted to people
before that just really
weren't good for you?
I have.
Well, there's a reason for that.
We can use that data.
We can use that to unlock
some of those patterns
and work with that.
But it's really important.
And how many of you have
been in a relationship
that the person
just made you crazy?
You're so freaking
turned on by them.
You're just like, oh my god.
I am not the only one
that has had that.
Great.
But what happens with that,
if they make you crazy,
and you keep in
relationship with them,
they'll make you crazy.
Because that's how it
starts and what happens.
So what we want to
look at, and I'm
going to work with
this in a bit,
is that the law of engagement,
not the law of attraction,
is what builds attraction and
fulfillment in relationships.
Engaging fully, really
knowing yourself
and another person is
what builds attraction.
Did any of you see-- actually,
it surfaced again not too long
ago in the "New York Times,"
"The 36 Questions of Intimacy--
How to Fall in
Love with Anybody."
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Yeah,
so it is fascinating.
The study was done
a long time ago,
but it surfaced recently again.
Arthur Aron did this.
There's a list of
36 questions that
have increasing
degrees of exposure,
and vulnerability, and truth.
And you also then look at
someone for four minutes.
Well, the people that did
this started feeling attracted
and loving toward one another.
They were total strangers.
So the moral of the story
is to get to know someone,
to be more revealed, to be
more real, is where the deeper
kinds of attraction come from,
not just that surface stuff,
which is what we need.
And again, getting to
know people at work
is just as important to getting
to know the people that you're
dating, or living with, or
are in the field for you.
The other is all
you need is love.
Well, yeah, no.
It's not at all.
Because relationships, like
any growing, organic thing,
need tending to.
They need sustenance.
They need resources.
You got to pull the weeds.
You got to give it the
nourishment that it needs.
And it takes skill, and
practice, and dedication.
Not just love.
This belief makes people
lazy in love, which I
think you can see in that way.
So the real truth about
this is great relationships
take a tremendous amount
of conscious effort.
It's really a conscious
thing to keep it in mind.
And usually, we're only
conscious of our relationships
in the beginning because
they're filling our mind.
But then once we
get used to them,
we're not as
conscious about them.
We're not as mindful
about what's going on.
And we don't put the
effort into them.
And we wonder why
they don't work.
We don't expect other areas
of our life to be that easy.
We enhance our career.
We work on our sports skills.
We do our yoga classes.
We do our mindfulness training.
We do things to get
better at things.
But we don't do this
for relationships.
We do lifelong training for
many things in our lives,
but not in relationships.
What's that about?
Because what's interesting,
we work more on our golf swing
sometimes than we do
on our relationships.
And relationships are the
most important thing to us,
but we're not putting in
what we could to do that.
And in fact, the
earlier you work
on relationships, the better.
Not waiting to have a problem,
doing it to enhance it.
So in fact, they did
a study of newlyweds.
The newlyweds that just
worked on their relationship
to have the best
relationship they could have
were three times more
likely to succeed
than those that waited till
they had a problem to seek
some counsel or some training.
So working on yourself,
and not the relationship,
is what really matters.
There's many people
who think we need
to work on the relationship.
No, you don't.
You need to work on you.
You becoming the most honest,
truthful, real, genuine, person
you can become, fighting the
battles you need to fight,
is what can shift
a relationship.
Nice if you have someone that
joins you in that journey,
but just you doing that
makes the difference.
And then you can bridge
it to the relationship.
So I'm hoping maybe you're a
little sobered by some of this.
I've needed to be
sobered by some of this.
And we've looked at what we
thought was good but isn't.
But I would like to
look at what does help
in having great relationships.
You can go on this journey.
I'll pick a couple of
these to work with.
We've been doing this study on
people who live great lives.
And we found that they not
only had these great lives
with amazing
vocational potential,
and they're making
more money, and they
were serving more
fully, their community
service was beautiful, their
missions, everything was
amazing.
But we found they had
this depth of intimacy
in their relationships
with their loved ones,
with their families,
with their coworkers,
with their employees.
And we're talking, whoa,
what are they doing?
So we studied them,
and it was interesting.
We found this fascinating
thing, that there
are these six skills-- I'm
not going to go into these,
I'm going to touch
on the first two
a little bit-- that not
only lead to great lives,
but lead to great relationships.
And we pulled this
research together first
in our book "Transformed."
And now, we're applying
it to relationships.
[? It's been ?] so fascinating
in "The Heart of the Fight"
that we're talking about today.
So the first thing, the first
skill here out of all these--
these are the six skills
that are in there,
so if you want more, you know
where to get it-- is yearning.
This yearning is really,
really, really important.
So I want to talk to you
a little bit about that.
Because yearning is the basis
of all of our relationships.
And I want to talk to
you about what these are.
Because when we're really
in touch with what we
really, deeply long
for, and we allow
that to guide us in our
moment to moment interactions,
even here, as we're in
this room right now.
The yearning that we all
have to love and be loved.
The yearning that we have
to be seen, to be heard,
to be understood, to be known.
The yearning we have to be
affirmed, to express ourselves,
to grow, to develop, to become.
The yearning to matter,
to make a difference,
to do what we came
here on Earth to do,
to be in touch
with our emotions.
If we are in touch
with those, we
can expect satisfaction moment
by moment by moment by moment.
There's always
something you can do
that can help you touch
those greater yearnings.
It's not a big move.
It's not a broad stroke.
But just in this moment, I'm
yearning to be heard by you.
I'm yearning to
connect with you.
I'm aware of those things
as I'm being with it,
and it brings a quality
to my experience.
I'm not saying that I
always fulfill that,
but I'm aware that that's
my hunger as I'm right here.
It matters to me that we relate.
I yearn to matter.
I hope I make a difference
for you in some way today
that something sparks that.
That's part of
what's fulfilling me
as I'm speaking this because
I'm in touch with why
I'm doing what I'm
doing and what matters.
And that's what's really
important in relationships.
Because any fight you
have is because you
have an unmet yearning.
Any conflict you have at work,
you have an unmet yearning.
Perhaps you yearn to be seen,
and you're not being seen.
You yearn to contribute,
and you're not
finding that in that way.
You yearn to be
understood, and you
don't feel that people
are really getting you.
You yearn to make a
difference, and you
don't feel like what
you're doing is having
the impact you want it to have.
You yearn to connect and
belong, and perhaps you're
not having this sense of
connection with your teammates
that you really yearned for.
The upset comes from
the unmet yearnings.
And any moment where you
feel like, oh, satisfied.
Oh, this feels so good.
That means your
yearnings have been met,
and that's why this
is important to really
be with this in that way.
And in order to work
with these yearnings,
we have to do
something about it.
We can't just yearn.
There's a great "Seinfeld"
clip-- do you yearn?
But we have to do
more than just yearn.
We have to really do
something about it.
We have to engage,
which is the next thing.
And I want to talk
about this more.
We have to engage in life, in
conflict, in our relationships,
in our work, in our teams.
Because what doesn't work
is the opposite of this.
We have to be willing to
get hurt, live unedited, be
made fun of, risk, be messy.
These kinds of things
are really important.
We have to go out of our comfort
zone in order to be real,
to have relationships.
Because relationships aren't
about being careful or walking
on eggshells.
They're about being
out there, and going
for what it is we
need and we want,
and being as honest as we can.
So it's also doing that, we
need to be willing to make
mistakes and make them boldly.
We're going to screw up.
If we're too careful,
we don't relate.
When we're too, oh,
what will they think.
I can't do that.
What will happen?
I need to wait until
he's in a good mood.
No, I need to wait until
when the boss has had lunch.
He's better after lunch.
I mean, yeah, somewhat.
But no, be with
what's true for you,
what really matters to you.
And act on those
yearnings in the moment.
So I'm going to give you
a little context on this.
This is in a
relationship continuum,
the engagement continuum.
On the left side,
there's all the stuff
that we do that's
neutral and destructive.
Actually, neutral
becomes destructive.
You end up going
backwards with that.
That's the stormiest
stuff of any relationship.
But we want to go
to what is it that's
going to be more constructive.
How do we have these
transformational kind
of relationships that
make a huge difference?
The key between these two
sides of this continuum
is being conscious and being
in touch with your yearnings
and having your feelings
available to you.
With that, something
much more powerful
can happen in our relationship.
So I'm going to show you
a little bit about what
we need on the right side in
this engagement continuum.
And I want to set this
context in saying this.
But relationships
aren't fragile.
I mean, if we treat them
like a hot house flower,
they're never going to flourish.
Most of you, I can't do that.
He can't take that.
She can't-- you have no idea
what people are capable of.
Relationships are resilient, way
more resilient than we expect.
And we're way too
careful oftentimes.
I don't mean you need to
be a toxic dump on people.
I don't mean that.
But I really do want
you to understand
that there is an importance
of being real and genuine.
So this whole part about
[GROANS]-- oh, did I miss one?
Oh, let me go.
All right.
Love is messy.
I love this photo.
Like, it's messy.
Are they having fun?
It's like, love is messy.
It's dirty.
We have to be willing
to get in there.
Fairy tales are all sanitized.
That "Notebook" scene?
That was messy.
They were out there.
They were yelling
at one another.
They were getting more
truth out in that way.
But true love is not
some sanitized version
of running across the
field in slow motion
or whispering sweet
nothings in somebody else's
ear or that field of
wildflowers or whatever that is.
It's just not about that.
Nor is it perfectly
synchronized,
beautifully synchronized,
no-sweat, no-fart sex.
That's not it.
I mean, it's like these
imaginary things that we think,
it's not it at all.
It's really full engagements,
rolling up your sleeves,
and being willing to get
into the relationship.
It's saying beautiful
things and hurtful things,
the things you
love and the things
you hate, the things you care
about deep in your heart,
the things you're afraid of,
the things that make you happy,
the things that bring you
joy, and being that revealed.
It's being open and
real and responsible.
But to do this, you need
some rules of engagement.
So I'm going to cover
a couple of these
because these are pretty
practical that you
can take in this.
The rules of
engagement we've found,
over all these years we've been
testing-- what is it that makes
for thriving relationships?
We use these in business.
We use them in families.
We use them in couples.
So see if you can
look at this one.
The first one may seem
kind of yeah, sure,
we should accentuate
the positive.
But I cannot tell you how
important this is because this
is looking for what's
positive in other people,
in your teammates, in your boss,
in the person you're dating,
in your loved ones,
in your family.
It's looking for
opportunities in your job
and your relationships.
It's looking for ways to grow.
How can I grow from
this situation?
It's being fully engaged
in it so that you
can build this backdrop
of trust and goodwill
so you can weather some
of the tougher times.
It's shifting your
perspective to see
what is there instead
of oftentimes,
just looking for what's
not there, what's missing.
But what is there?
Chances are there's a lot
more than you've seen.
See, and the other
thing I want you
understand about
romantic relationships,
intimate relationships.
Relationships do not break up
because people are fighting.
They break up because they
don't have enough of this.
You have enough positives
built up, like in your bank.
You can weather a
lot of difficulties.
You've got good will that
you can work things through.
And this is what's
missing for most people.
missing in teams.
This is what's missing
at work a lot of times.
And it's what's missing in
the quality of our lives.
And I wanted to give you
some examples of what
this is, that the research
shows-- and ours does,
as well-- that we have to
be conscious about this,
looking for it, grabbing
it, soaking it in, really
allowing ourselves to have
that, be there for ourselves.
So things like more humor,
having more joy and more fun,
goofy, spontaneous interacting.
I mean, you have a
slide in this building.
I mean, you have
all kinds of ways
to be able to engage that
can help you break out
of the norms of these
social constraints.
But it's also showing interest
and curiosity in other people,
asking real, genuine
questions, and wanting
to hear the answer to them,
not just how was your day.
How was your day?
Someone comes back
from a meeting--
what happened at the meeting?
How was it?
Really being interested in
what's going on with people
and really being present to
whatever that is for yourself
and to the other person.
And this one, I mean, I know.
We all know about being present.
But it's really difficult
because we're usually
thinking about something
else and the next thing.
You are right now.
How many of you are present
with what I'm talking about?
I hope you are because
that would be great.
But our minds go a lot
of different places.
To bring ourselves back, to be
present in the moment with what
we're experiencing.
So this also means that
we need to be accessible.
We need to be available.
We need to be
responsive and learn
to be more responsive to
others in that way, and also,
emotionally engaged,
not just intellectually,
not just with our minds,
which is really important.
This is one.
How many of you want more
appreciation and affirmation?
I'm just going to-- you don't
have to do laundry to get it,
even though it's
like doing that.
You can.
That is one way.
But it's really important
because also, men
need it more than women.
And oftentimes, we don't
show the appreciation
and affirmation, or
appreciation for just the
doing that happens, the doing
the laundry, whatever that is.
This one, I think,
you can all relate to.
Who wants more affection
in their lives?
I did, too.
But I wasn't as willing to be as
affectionate as I needed to be.
My husband was more affectionate
with me than I was to him.
And I really had to
go to school on him.
I was shier.
It's very vulnerable
to be affectionate.
Now, I'm cuddlier
and everything.
I had to work on that.
But look at these.
Yeah, who doesn't
want some of that?
You know?
I love these.
Aw, to have your
relationship go to that.
Yeah.
And PDAs are really important.
Public displays of affection
are really, really important
because that's saying
in public, I care.
I'm here.
I'm with you.
You matter to me.
I'm willing to be seen
as someone who loves you.
It's a really important
thing for us to share.
Another is to be more
supportive and to be
an advocate for others and to
inspire each other in this way.
I'm just going to
give you a sense
of being engaged in that way.
Another one is celebrating
other people's victories
and their wins as if
they were your own,
being as excited for what
goes well for people.
What these studies
are showing is
that it's much more
important than being there
when somebody is
down, that it really
is what brings them more the
depth of connection for people.
And taking risks, saying the
unsayable, doing the undoable,
really just going beyond
wherever you would have been.
And I think you can
understand this.
Gifts and variety and
surprises are important.
Boredom is an issue
at work, at home,
in your romantic relationships.
And it's up to you to
create the sense of newness.
And sharing your dreams and
your hopes with everyone,
with people at work, with your
family, with your beloved.
Really allowing people to
know you by sharing your hopes
and your dreams makes
a huge difference.
They did studies
of couples talking.
And it's interesting.
They just studied all the
things a couple talked about
during a week.
Most couples talk about
logistics and stuff and plans.
And at the max, couples
had 17 minutes a week
where they talked about
something other than logistics.
I know.
And that's common.
So really bridging this to what
we really need to be doing.
And sharing our fears
with one another,
and our missions,
what matters to us.
And where we're headed
in our lives in that way.
Having a sense of shared
meaning and purpose
is really important.
Rachel, can you do
this thing with me?
Can you stand up and do a
thing with me for a second?
All right, so Rachel and
I are in relationship.
So at this level-- so
we're in relationship.
So now put your hand up here.
If you have a mission
and I have a mission,
we have a higher purpose,
the fighting and the stuff
within the relationship, this
doesn't have so far to go.
It can work through that.
But if we don't have this, this
is where the stuff happens.
There's no reason to
work stuff through.
Well, I hope that
demo-- OK, great.
It's really important,
makes a big difference.
And I thank you for that.
So this one is obviously
really important.
Having a sense of
vision, looking
beyond the horizon, where you're
going, what matters to you,
and sharing that
with one another.
This kind of way of
accentuating the positive
keeps you mentally fit.
It is like a form of active
mindfulness in your life
and applying it
to relationships.
We call Mindfulness 2.0, because
it's engaged in the moment, not
just a meditation,
which we love as well,
but to really be mindful
of our relationships
and what helps craft
that and craft us.
It's living more
mindfully moment
by moment with one
another and with others.
And we are responsible for
our own mental fitness.
And this is what actually helps
us train our hearts, as well.
I'm just going to
go a little bit.
I should probably just
end it on the positive.
I'm going to give
you one other rule.
Then I'll show you.
Then we'll do a thing to
wrap this up in a bit.
The other part of this, we
need to minimize the negative.
So we need to be build
this basis of the positive.
But we need to
minimize the negative.
And in fact, why I didn't
show this one first,
this one-- minimize
the negative.
For every snarky,
icky thing we do,
every mean-spirited,
every whatever we do,
the research shows we need
five of those positives
to just balance off that one.
And we're all
going to be snarky.
We're going to do stupid things.
We're going to say mean things.
We're going to hurt
people's feelings.
It's part of being human.
Just take responsibility for it.
Don't be so careful.
But also know
you've got to build
this backlog of all
the other great stuff
so that you can weather this.
I mean, you being real
is really important.
So let's look at these.
The things to not do, we need to
decrease, is avoiding conflict.
You avoid conflict,
you're avoiding intimacy.
You're avoiding creativity.
You're avoiding
possibilities in relationship
at work or at home.
I have a couple of these.
Yeah, talk to the hand.
Also not hiding out, whether
that's in your relationship
or at work.
It's very damaging
to relationships.
It's very, very costly to that.
Having secrets, having
the real conversations
at work in the hallways
rather than at the meetings,
or talking behind people's
back, or gossiping
rather than being
straight with people,
is another part of the issue.
Gossip, drama, but
also being checked out,
kind of disengaged, that's
damaging to relationships
and damaging to work,
in teams at work.
There's so many of these.
And I know many of you know
Gottman's work probably.
But he has these four horsemen
of the apocalypse, the four
things that they
found are just really
destructive to relationships.
Withdrawing, oh, this is
another disengaged one.
Is that so zoned?
Let me give you this one.
Withdrawing and stonewalling,
really not engaging,
is really deadly
to a relationships.
Being defensive and
passive aggressive,
whether you literally
flip the bird or not.
But that's a defense
that you have.
Being critical is
part of this as well,
really being really critical
of the person, not just what
they're doing, but also
contempt and disgust.
And that can look a
lot of ways, from eye
rolling to mockery to hostile
humor, all kinds of things.
Or just really going
at it this way at work
could be a pretty
big problem for you.
But sometimes you want to.
You're just so mad.
You can't stand it.
It's like, they're
so bothering you.
But part with that is to really
learn how to deliver criticism
with a vision.
Yes, I don't like
what you're doing.
You're driving me crazy.
I hate it.
And this is the
possibility I see.
So they know that you see
their higher self at the same
you're really frustrated
or angry with what's there.
But holding the tension
of both of those
is extremely important.
And I'm going to go quickly
through a few others,
just to sum this up for
us and then look at this.
Third rule, these are
about responsibility.
Nobody gets to take or give
more than 50% of the blame.
You can blame.
But it takes two to tango.
So this is really
important for us to see.
So it's your fault. No,
it's your fault. No.
Did too.
Did not.
How many of you have
still second grade fights?
I still do with my husband.
Did too.
Did not.
They're not terribly productive,
you may have noticed,
because they're
defensive and also blame.
So looking at this, what
could I have done differently
in this relationship?
How can I take my
50% of the blame?
What could I have said or
done or set it up differently
or made it more likely that
I get what it is I wanted?
Am I communicating
my expectations?
Am I training the people at
work in order to meet those?
Am I giving them
effective feedback?
Or am I just sitting there
resenting that they're not
doing what I want them to
do and being mad about it,
but not taking my 50% blame
and doing something about it?
So related to this,
everybody, each of us
is 100% responsible for our
own satisfaction and happiness.
That's important that you're
100% responsible for creating
value at this talk.
I can't do that for you.
That's yours to do.
I'll give you as much as I can.
You're 100% responsible
for creating value
in your job, in your work,
on a date, in a meeting,
in a conversation.
That's yours.
You can do that.
No one else can do that for you.
And really, it's
so, so important.
We had a woman in
our program who
did our Signature program, this
Year of Transformation program.
When she began, she was married.
She'd been married
for 30-some years.
And she would talk
about her husband.
She called him whatshisname.
Whatshisname, I
never knew his name.
She said, well, whatshisname.
And she'd kind of sneer.
Whatshisname, da-da-da-da-da.
And she was complaining
about him all the time.
All he did was watch TV.
He wasn't supportive, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
She started to use these
rules of engagement,
took her part of the blame,
took 100% of the responsibility.
It's pretty amazing.
Two years later, now,
she's very deeply in love.
So is he.
He's had some health challenges.
She's been there fully for him.
It's really been quite
an amazing journey.
She cries talking
about him, she's
so moved with her love for him.
And he didn't do anything.
He responded to her.
She started taking--
of course he
did because she was
changing the system.
But she was taking
responsibility,
going for being satisfied
instead of just blaming it
all on him.
And it really led to this
beautiful, satisfying
relationship.
100%.
So if you see that, when
everybody at work, if everybody
is taking 100%
responsibility, what happens
is that everybody puts
together what they--
the solutions are
amazing when that
occurs, that the creativity
and the problem solving that
happens.
We use this in businesses a lot.
And it's really critically
important for what
ends up happening.
So I'm going to give
you another one.
Yeah, going for satisfaction.
Express and agree
with the truth always.
Always.
Do you know?
And some of you are dating.
100% of dating couples lie.
That means all of us.
That means every
single one of us.
We don't tell the truth.
We're trying to impress
each other or whatever.
That causes a big problem.
So actually, telling
the truth, but also
when someone else tells the
truth that you tell the truth.
You remember, you acknowledge
the truth when it's being said.
You take it in, that
you use straight talk.
You're real.
You're genuine.
You don't go around the bush.
You're just straight out.
You give real feedback, and you
take it when it comes your way.
It's very, very important for
us to be willing to look at that
and to tell the truth,
to really tell the truth,
to be willing to really say,
what so cross your heart.
And I hope you don't die.
But just being willing
to do that in a way.
Another one I'm going
to quickly go to
is fighting for
something, not just
against someone or their point.
This is really important
because oftentimes, in conflict,
you start fighting
against somebody.
So if you can, in conflict,
remember what's your purpose.
What is it that you wanted?
What's the outcome
that you wanted?
What's your desired outcome?
So you're not fighting
against someone or their point
or just resisting,
but you're fighting
for what you yearn
for so that you
have a direction for
your conversations.
And there's another,
huge-- assuming good will.
This one's a little tough
because in a relationship,
it's really hard in
a fight or conflict
or whatever to remember that
this is your beloved, that this
is your friend when you're so
mad, or so hurt, or so scared.
They're not just out to get you.
They're hurt and
angry or scared.
And that's how it's
playing out of that way.
And at work, rather
than assuming ill will
and turning your boss
and your coworkers
into the ugly stepmother
and stepsister, to you
really show your belief
in them and encourage them
toward a higher vision.
Try to assume the good will.
Look for it and it's there.
And then you'll see them as the
people that they really are.
And you can bring out
much greater gits in them.
Even when they have
a negative attitude,
to see the possibilities
that are in that.
This is another one
about assuming good will.
I want to give you this one
because emotional intelligence,
extremely related to
what I'm talking about.
There's a part, I don't
know if you can recognize.
When you really get
mad or really scared
and your heart's beating
really fast, how many of you
know that feeling?
You're just taken
over in that way?
You're really
flooded with emotion.
You're in this high
physiological arousal state.
If your heart beats
100 beats a minute
and you're not
working out, you're
under the influence of this
thing that's happening.
But what happens when
we're in that state
is we don't see what's there.
Our perception really changes.
We start to see negativity
where it doesn't exist.
We coat neutral
things with negative.
We miss 50%, at least,
of the positive things
that are going on around us.
And we need to know
that it's not real.
It's just we're
clouded in that moment.
If we train ourselves
harmonically
to look for what is there,
we can shift out of that.
So I'm going to wrap this now
and bring some things together
for us.
But I want to look at all these
things that we've been looking
at, these rules of engagement.
I'm hoping you can
find at least one that
you could practice
today, this afternoon,
tonight, throughout the
week, that you could
take a little more
responsibility for,
a little more truth here,
maybe add a little positive,
diminish a little
of that negative,
just even a little bit in
that way because what happens
is we start to
then discover what
the true purpose of
relationships are,
that relationships aren't
there to make us happy.
We should have some happy,
enjoyable moments, of course.
To share your life with
another human being,
any other human being,
is a great, great gift.
But it really is to challenge
us and awaken us and help
us develop into who we
could become, to grow
and transform and realize our
potential, to serve as both
the womb for nurturing us and
supporting us and soothing
us and tending to us, but also
a crucible for growth so that it
keeps us on our edge
for what's possible,
to be challenged
by it in that way,
to bust those myths and
beliefs that are limiting us,
and to really believe
in the possibilities
so that we can create this
heroic kind of love we talked
about earlier where
we tap that potential.
We're every day heroes,
sharing our deepest yearnings,
telling deeper
truths, going for it,
taking risks, making mistakes,
engaging, encountering others
more fully, not
being so careful,
being real, becoming a
transformation in ourselves,
and then contributing to
transformational relationships
wherever we are, being
that light in that way.
Being willing to engage in the
tough battles and conflicts
and fight things through,
to get satisfied,
and get to the deeper
truth about what's
really going on in that
way, to be on the cutting
edge of possibilities.
And this is the first time
in history relationships
have been able to
get to this point.
We had many other purposes
throughout history.
Now, there's a potential for
both transformation and contact
that we've never had
before, and that's
going to be ours to do that,
and those that come beyond us.
So I'm suggesting we
start it, that we become
as real and authentic as we
can, and use these skills
to do that, to be a new model
of intimacy and partnership
in our lives.
And I want to wrap up
a little bit with this.
I know that it takes a
lot of skill to do this.
I know in my own life, I am
continually learning new skills
to do this-- and practice.
And I would love to
support you with that.
And I told earlier I
had a gift for you.
Let me give you that.
And so also for the livestream,
I'll give you a way to do that.
There is a flier and a
little card right here.
We do a weekend training
in these skills,
which is really powerful.
You have experiences of it.
You learn about it.
You're practicing
all kinds of things
to really have these great
relationships and great lives.
Ordinarily, we would charge
$800 for this training.
It's complementary
to all of you.
I'd love to have you come.
It's in Chicago.
It's a wonderful place to visit.
I would love to see you again.
And all you need to do
is fill out this card.
We do five a year.
This would hold a space
in any one of the five
that you could come to.
You may not know
what that is yet.
You can just put, I'll
check my calendar.
Or I'll check it out.
But by doing this,
you hold a spot.
And I'll make sure that you get
your complementary admission.
Also, we're doing a
raffle today because I
want to give you more support.
We have some wonderful
prizes, some books
and some other
things to give you.
So if you fill
this out, then you
can participate in
the raffle as well.
And on the livestream,
let me give you
a link that you can go to.
This is the training
that I'm talking about.
And you get these skills
of social and emotional
intelligence to live
these beautifully.
And on the livestream or if
you're watching this by video,
you can go to this link as well.
So if you take a second
and fill those out.
And I want to make sure you get
your prizes before you leave.
And Katie and Maria will
pick those up from you.
And if you have any
questions while they're
doing that, I would love to
entertain those before we take
off, anything you want-- or
anything you want to say,
any genuine, real, truthful
thing you want to say,
I'd love to you hear as well.
RACHEL: I know
we're out of time,
but if anyone has
a burning question?
AUDIENCE: Can we clap?
RACHEL: No, we can give
a round of applause.
Thank you.
JUDITH WRIGHT: Lovely,
thank you for that.
Thank you.
It's been a joy to be with you.
And again, if I can support you
in any way, I would love to.
And let me know.
I will be here to sign books or
answer any personal questions
if you'd like, as
well, for a little bit
before I fly back
to Chicago today.
But thank you.
Thank you for being in
a relationship with me.
I really appreciate that
opportunity to be with you.
So shall we go, love well?
Are you up for it?
Who's up for it?
Let's go love well.
Let's go love well and often.
OK, great.
Thank you.
RACHEL: Thank you, Judith.
JUDITH WRIGHT: And if you
want to give these cards,
we'll make sure you hopefully
get your prizes quickly.
And I'd love to see you.